you have so much pain in you you
you some much's
rage that you can't contain it so the
first thing I want to touch on is an
epic fight scene that we see in the
first episode it's the warehouse fight
scene and I'm curious given that fight
scene is made to look like a wner what
is the single most difficult part of
that F choreography for
you in the warehouse the most difficult
part
is when I enter the room for the first
time and I see the fight happening that
choreography there's a lot of stuff
involved there's punching you know
there's choking I have to choke a guy as
well all of that moment and then from
that point on it was continued and we
did not stop but probably the hardest
part it that was probably the hardest
part but it was so fun and we had to
fight with the heat literally the
temperature that was inside the building
as well we had fans of course but when
there's when we were rolling we had to
turn the fans off and so it was very
sweaty but it was just so fun that was
probably the challenging part and it all
paid off because it looks absolutely
incredible oh I appreciate that thanks
so the next fight I want to touch on is
your fight with Daredevil because we do
get a glimpse of that in the trailer can
you tell us a little bit about working
on that fight and maybe in particular
things you were able to do to inhance
how different um Ekko and Daredevil's
fight styles
are yeah so obviously they have both
different death or different fighting
styles one of I'm deaf and he is blind
so
yeah
I only worked with him for a day but we
did do a lot of practice with the
choreography and the stunt training
beforehand you know we had some sess
sessions before that but I was able to
learn that choreography with Daredevil
the last minute on the same day so it
was very much like get up and go very
fast-paced and it was new choreography
with Daredevil so that was probably the
challenge that's so complicated I'm so
impressed you picked up on all that so
quickly yeah thank thank God I was I
grew up uh with an older brother that
kind of helped with my tolerance and
athleticism with that glad that paid off
all right the next thing I wanted to
touch on was your collaboration with
Vincent because he's just a
one-of-a-kind Force onet where you
really feel the weight of his
performance so as his scene partner do
you notice him doing anything unique or
different that allows him to have that
kind of authority in a
scene I know that he's been acting for
such a long time and I notice on set
I'll never forget this when the director
was trying to talk to him about a
certain scene they were talking about
something in Kingpin he was giving all
these suggestions and these ideas about
Kingpin and I was just sitting back
watching and I was like gosh he's such
an expert he could be the he's working
with a director as an actor and he is
kind of all these things all encumbers
into one and so he I was watching him
give all this feedback and these ideas
without any hesitation and I think I
would be a little bit hesitated to give
any suggestions because I am such an
introverted person as well but he's just
so knowledgeable in this acting world so
just seeing his knowledge is beautiful
and just he's a great guy to work with
as well I love hearing that to tease
where Maya is at at her in her her
journey at the very beginning of the
show after she returns home at that
point in the story what would you say
her greatest strength is but then I also
want to know what you think her greatest
weakness is the thing she's going to
have to overcome throughout the show in
order to become a stronger hero and
person that's a good question um I would
say her strength is obviously she is so
resist resilient and she's able to build
up that res resilience you know she has
her ancestors that help her with her
superpowers that make her become even
more resilient and probably a weakness
of hers
is trying to reconnect with faith in
humanity and finding out what the
definition of family is but she's able
to work on that through her story and
she's able to work on having those Roots
reconnected with her family such a good
answer spot on this is one of my
favorite questions to end on lately cuz
I'm a big believer that no one in this
business tells themselves good job
nearly enough so can you tell me
something you did while making Echo that
you know you can look back on and say to
yourself damn I am proud of what I did
there first of all I am so damn proud of
myself I thought that I would never be
able to finish the show but you know we
I did that and I had the support of
co-workers along the entire way and the
support of directors and everybody just
came together and helped me through it
and that's probably what my proudest
moment is is because I did
it
Maya I see everything that you
are I always
have so my first question for you is
what happens to someone after they are
shot like Fisk is is there anything
about him after the fact that makes him
more dangerous than ever I I think that
you know it it does in the long run I
think it it means a lot in a very kind
of the way we played it out it it's um
is subtle and you understand why he
shows up and tries to get him back her
back not just the fact that they have
this kind of fatherdaughter relationship
but the fact that he why he comes back
after she's shot him and what he does to
heal himself and and what he plans on
what he thinks the outcome is going to
be it's it all is it's it's all kind of
tied together in a very kind of subtle
way so to get the flip side of that now
at this point in his journey what do you
think his greatest weaknesses the
potential thing that could do him in on
his mission
now you know it's an interesting
question because the last episode of
this series deals with that a little bit
and
um there's a battle that takes place
over that exact subject so I really
can't say anything about it oh I'll take
that that UPS my Intrigue for the end of
the SE and so so much here's one other
weakness question for you is is he
unkillable how has he survived what he
has survived at this point because MCU
Canon says so that's why it's an
excellent answer to that question right
there I have to ask about your
collaboration with alaka now because it
is a major standout what is something
about her as a scene partner that you
really appreciate that maybe helps you
reach something in your own character
that you wouldn't have been able to find
with without her every scene that we did
together I mean every scene that we did
together it I I couldn't have um I mean
I rarely expect the scene to turn out in
a certain way anyway but this in
particular she's just so good she's so
talented and you know the fact that
she's so new and she's able to be this
confident and this strong on a set you
know it was a there's some very intense
stuff in this in this series between her
and my character and um ala just nailed
it every time she's just immensely
immensely talented and you know the
action stuff too I saw just the the
other day I saw the long one of the long
fight scenes that she has and it's just
amazing you don't question for a second
that she can't kick these people's butt
you know it's amazing I know uh you're
not allowed to tell us a whole lot about
uh Daredevil born again but I am curious
to hear a little bit maybe about how
your collaboration with Charlie has
evolved and actually maybe particularly
his craft given you worked together
before is there anything that you saw
him do on that set that made you go like
I knew you were good in that role but I
never realized you were capable of doing
that I mean always with Charlie or
Charlie and I are good friends so it's
really not you know like it's I I just
adore the guy you know he's he's he's
he's a really prepared and talented
actor and um you know he doesn't mess
about you know like the two of us are
similar and that we don't um waste a lot
of time when we're acting and um we just
like to get come in get the job done and
and uh he and and and bring and bring a
whole life to it and and and Charlie
does that
um uh I remember when we first started
the Netflix series um I had to do the
first scene that we actually did
together I was off camera uh on a
walkie-talkie and you never see it was a
different day you see my we shot my side
on a different day and his side on a
different day so so I was like offscreen
watching him and feeding him lines over
the walkie-talkie and I had never seen
him do a scene before and so just the
way he moved around the office and
jumped up on the furniture and stuff I
was like oh my God this is this is show
is going to work like this is that guy
just you know jumped up on that desk
without any effort whatsoever and is
delivering these lines the way he was
and I thought this is going to work like
really in one in one scene just watching
him I knew that the whole series was
going to work it was pretty
amazing so first I want to tease both of
your characters can you each tell me
something they stand to gain from from
my returning home but then I also want
to know a potential problem that that
poses for them ooh that's a great
question question uh for Uncle Henry
forgiveness and a potential problem
Maya I don't know what Maya's you know
doesn't know what May's going to do it's
it's yeah I'd say that that would be it
a fair answer yeah I think for Bonnie
for the character I play uh what she
stands to gain for Maya coming home as a
sister they grew up together even though
technically they're cousins like they're
more like sisters and and I think the
problem that her returning poses is she
kind of has to learn who her cousins
become which is this anti-hero which is
this person who's really violent and
involved in organized crime so I think
it's um it raises some pretty
complicated emotions for Bonnie there's
such a good description right there oh
thanks I want to come back your way to
ask you about reuniting with Sydney I
only spoke to her for seven minutes but
she seems incredible yes given the fact
that you've worked with her before what
is something she did on the set of echo
that made you go like I knew you were
really good but I never realized you
were capable of doing that oh my God
Sydney was just such a rock star through
all of it she's been like eat sleep and
breath breathing Echo even before all of
it her dog is named Echo um I met echo
which is so like so sweet um yeah I
think I always knew Sydney was was a
badass and would really command it I
think there's some scenes that are
coming for like the grand finale that
are the ones that really solidifi that
she was the person to uh Shepherd this
story uh but one of my favorite things
on set of working with Sydney was she's
she's somebody who's like pretty softs
spoken and she's really calm and
level-headed and almost like a little
bit shy like a lot of native people are
and um but there there was something
about her signing when she is speaking
ASL to to alaka that like all of a
sudden this super outgoing person would
come and she would be like good nice and
she was like so animated and big that I
was like I love this do you two see her
doing a monitor dance at all does she do
anything behind the monitor that signals
to you she's really digging a take I
didn't oh she's like in it she's got her
headphones on and she's w
and then after this is a sign for nice
and she be like nice nice she would be
like so into it I'll take that all right
I'll use this as my excuse to ask my
reservation dogs question because
obviously the show has come to a close
and I know sometimes when you're a
little far removed and you have time to
reflect you can find new things about it
that you appreciate even more than when
you were doing it so has that happened
to you just based on yourself or maybe
based on viewer reaction as well I think
getting to share the last and and final
season with audiences is obviously sweet
um it was really beautiful and and I
still don't know that I fully reckoned
with the fact that it's over because we
haven't really had a chance to talk
about it yet um but there were so many
people who worked on echko who were from
reservation dogs we had a lot of
crossover uh and I think I was really I
think I'm just really grateful and
fortunate enough to be a part of both of
these really awesome projects I think
that's a fair statement right there you
also wrote and directed on that so it
was making me wonder and I know you're a
comic reader too if you could write
Andor direct for any Marvel character
which would you choose and why oh my
gosh that's such a that's such a good
question I would
probably if they continue with uh any
Echo comics and moving forward I would
love to be able to write for Maya
Lopez I like the sound of that I'll plus
one that could happen CH I'll I'll toss
that back to you of all of the Marvel
shows and films that have come out thus
far I want to know which is your
favorite but I also want to know which
one you can't pick your wrong
that's I also want to know which one
surprised you the most and maybe made
you realize like all the storytelling
possibilities that the franchise has to
offer okay so the first one is what was
my favorite favorite that's the easy one
that's why I to add a second one I you
know I I would say uh Iron Man the first
yeah the classic one I I really like
that one and was the second question one
that you saw that kind of surprised you
and like blew the door open to all of
the creative possibilities that the
Marvel Cinematic Universe has to offer
Thor
Ragnarok yeah I thought that was
something brilliant I thought I don't
know what it was the its way it was shot
the music the pce I don't know what it
was but Ragnarok I really I really think
that that's a phenomenal a plus choice
right there so I was reading that
everyone on this set learned American
Sign Language to make the show can you
tell me like a favorite sign like a
phrase that stuck with you but then
also we
aound question though of course I also
want to know a tip you might give to
somebody else out there who maybe
watches this and then feels inspired to
learn themselves yeah I think the the
tip would be patience with
yourself um and knowing that this is how
people
communicate and you should
be very grateful that you're learning
this for these people and being able to
uh yeah I think yeah just being grateful
that you're you're able to participate
in that world what your favorite sign do
you have a favorite sign I do I do Maya
taught it to me or Loa taught it to me
is it camera on are we going to have to
blur it out yeah show it out okay right
here
yeah love
it that's cute mine's a little more like
G-rated Mine mine's PG okay what is it
my favorite sign is comfortable cuz I'm
a I'm super cozy in my life like I
always like to be comfy so comfortable
it feel like a perfect sign for it okay
okay I like that and then the any tips
that was your question right any tips
for people who are wanting to learn ASL
I would say to learn from deaf teachers
I think that's really important to learn
about Deaf culture and to learn about
the the language from the people who who
were raised with it and who are willing
to teach it I had a chance to learn ASL
from The Sign Language Center who's been
really incredible and and they really uh
promote having instructors H great
answers right there I'll squeeze in one
more before I have to leave you because
you have such an exceptional ensemble in
the show can you each name a Time on set
when a scam partner gave you just what
you needed and maybe that helped you
access something in your own character
that you wouldn't have been able to
reach without
them yeah I don't go into it though but
it it dealt with aa oh spoilers
yeah I don't know if it's a spoiler but
it was a very emotional scene and and
she helped me out a lot on that so I
appreciate that I want to
know curious um I would also have to say
working with alqua there was um there's
such a a complicated history between
Maya and Bonnie and and so much hurt but
also so much love and so we did a lot of
work in making sure that we were able to
feel the history between them and to to
feel the the heartache and missing each
other and so yeah I think it was just
like it's one thing to be able to read a
script and to practice like ASL but it's
another to to act off of a human being
and and to connect with ala And the
emotions that she gave and then also the
moments where she shut me out
intentionally as Maya were really really
effective in in activating Bonnie to
like get frustrated and be like no
listen like um yeah to because Bonnie's
whole goal is to reconnect her
family tigers moving silence to catch
their
prey you are a tiger
May what did you do first question for
you is about signing on for this show
when you first joined the echo team what
is something you were really eager to
bring to Maya's story and the character
too but then also can you tell me
something you found along the way that
wound up being really important for you
to emphasize yeah you know I think when
I first when I first pitched on the
project and when I had that the
opportunity to speak with Kevin you know
one of the things that I remember
mentioning was like I grew up reading
comic books specifically Marvel comic
books and I grew up going to powwow and
those two things like never overla there
was no intersect I read comic books at
pow wows and I probably um I actually I
never saw a PO in a comic book but um
but those two things never overlap they
never intersected with each other and
the both exciting and terrifying thing
about this is that those two things came
smashing together so it was like for
myself personally it was just an
opportunity to to do something that I
hadn't even imagined myself if something
isn't terrifying it's not exciting at
all it's not exciting especially in this
industry yeah yeah so you get an
opportunity to direct the pilot episode
and kind of set the tone and style for
future episodes so are there any
specific things you deliberately strove
to do in episode one that we'll see in
every episode of Eko yeah you know I
think I think with a authenticity being
important like it wasn't a maybe it was
a must for for for myself and everyone
involved um and so I'm indigenous but
I'm not deaf so one of the first things
that I did and my department heads did
and my and my crew did is that we all
started taking ASL classes early on and
um that actually end up dictating our
entire visual style so what do I mean by
that um uh you know in our in so for
example between you and I speaking right
now the words coming out of my mouth
that's the text but the way I'm
delivering those words that's the
subtext right so those two things give
the full emotional intent of what I'm
trying to communicate to you in ASL it's
slightly different so when you sign it's
typically here or here and the signing
that's the text right but the the facial
expressions and the way that you emote
and express that through body language
that's the subtext so you need both the
signing and the facial expression to get
the full emotional con context right so
what does that mean that means in our
show this is a closeup so to get and
because this is a closeup for Mya Lopez
and Alo that means that's a closeup for
everybody else so in this case that was
a very positive consequence that came
from us taking it classes and it ended
up dictating the entire visual style for
the show I am very curious to hear about
the action style as well because one
thing you do exceptionally well like
even in the first episode Al alone is
put us in her shoes as she's
experiencing these fights so can you
talk about some techniques you use to
give us that feeling yeah you know I
think um uh again without spoiling
anything in the first episode there's a
action set piece that is one shot
Warehouse is exceptional I am obsessed
with wers that is high up on my list oh
hell well done hell yeah thank you thank
you um a lot of people worked very very
hard on that um you know and I think but
again because everything stems from
story and and looking at the page the
thing that I loved about that was that
Mya Lopez entered that scene as a
teenage girl but she left as a cold
blooded killer and so it was always
important for me that the audience and
her that we were able to see that trans
transformation take place in real time
and um and so that lent itself to the
Warner nature of how we shot it and I
remember in talking with Mark skiak our
stunt coordinator and we were talking
like oh man this is ambitious we're on a
TV schedule and you know you watch those
you know some of our influences like
Atomic blonde or uh you know there's a
great fight sequence in there um you
know some John Wicks I think lady
Vengeance was another one they have
weeks and weeks and weeks I think I
think Tom had like 10 weeks of of
rehearsal we had probably two weeks and
so we knew was ambitious going in but we
wanted to take a big swing it's
exceptional it pays off you jumped into
that so so well because we get a glimpse
of him in the trailer I'll also ask
about directing a daredevil fight too
what are some specifics to his fighting
style that opened up some like new
creative doors for you to explore when
crafting that oh you know it was
interesting
because the in the one of the first
meetings with Charlie and he's a very
thoughtful uh actor and he takes a lot
of he puts a lot of thought into the
character and you can see why that that
that of the series was such a success
um in addition to you know beyond the
writing as well too but in the very
first meeting he he said he said if
Daredevil is blind and my Lopez is deaf
how do they communicate and we were
already months into prep at this pro at
this point and and I was sort of
dumbfounded along you know my producers
were there as well too and we were like
we haven't even thought of that oh my
goodness we have to go back to the
drawing board and so we went back and it
sparked all these conversations but um
you know I think uh I'm trying to think
what a specific Daredevil moment came
about I'm trying to I'm trying to think
of something without spoiling it but
understandable understandable we don't
want to spoil anything too soon but what
I saw A+ yet again exceptional fight
scene um I did want to bring up
reservation dogs because there are a
bunch of people from that show that are
now working on this can you talk a
little bit about the value of building a
film making family and why that can
enhance a finished product when you're
working with people that you've worked
with before yeah I mean it's interesting
because you know reservation dogs was
sort of like we all know each other and
so we're all friends and so when the
opportunity came to make this like we've
all known each other in some cases for
decades um and so when and but in
addition to that the Native American
Community is um is small you know it is
small it's a tight-knit group we all
talk to each other we all know each
other and um so in this case with
something like this like you know
bringing in Dey and and Cody lightning
and you know alako Cox I had worked with
before chasuk Spencer was somebody I
admired for a long time uh Graham
greaham and tantu Cardinal were I grew
up watching them you know so to have the
opportunity to bring them in it was both
it was a chance to bring in both your
Heroes and your friends and and and just
smash them in together oh it's so
effective here I have one uh
reservations dog reservation dogs ending
question for you too because like now
we're we're a little far removed from it
and sometimes when you could think back
to something it could you know take on
take on new light or you can come to to
appreciate things in it more than you
have before so given that the story is
now complete is there anything that is
more powerful than you ever anticipated
it could be when you first started
working on the show on reservation talks
yeah oh my goodness yeah I think uh it's
interesting because when the first when
the first um season came out about
halfway through the season Sterling was
was I think we're on set no I think
we're on set and he came to us he said
you know Hulu the Hulu Executives they
came to us and he said we're getting all
these spikes and viewership in these
random parts of the country uh Montana
Wyoming South Dakota North Dakota
Arizona New Mexico uh Oklahoma uh
Minnesota Washington they're so random
and Sterling was like those are all
places where there are
reservations and you know I think that
Illustrated this sort of Disconnect of
there isn't a an audience or there isn't
viewership for Native American content
and that and that simple conversation
proved that there absolutely
is
my first questions are about Marvel
Spotlight first what does it mean to
have Ekko being the show to kick off the
Marvel Spotlight Banner it is really
awesome for us uh it's awesome for me
personally that I got to work on Ekko
which is the first under the Marvel
Spotlight Banner uh like a lot of things
we do here at the studio it was rooted
in the comics in the ' 70s there was a
series of Marvel Spotlight comics where
some hugely iconic characters that are
still around today like Ghost Rider and
Spiderwoman they first got their main
first real story in a Marvel Spotlight
comic so we have all these characters
from the larger Comics cannon that we
want to tell stories about and now that
we have you know marvel television that
we can we can show these characters and
tell these stories it was just a way for
us to say like hey here's a character
that's a little more obscure from the
comics but we hope you enjoy this show
about them I know it's been teased that
they'll be contained stories that will
hopefully allow you to take big creative
swings but is there anything about how
Ekko could set the tone for the band
that you're really looking forward to
exploring yeah and it all just happened
kind of naturally you know we are the
first TV MA show for Marvel Studios I
have questions about that um were the
first show being released on Hulu and
Disney Plus at the same time um so yeah
I just think that there's for different
shows there's different release models
and different stories being told on
different platforms it's just a fun and
exciting thing that we have all these
opportunities to do different things
right now so one more question about
Spotlight because I am curious about the
rules of Spotlight rules is my okay well
that might answer this question is Maya
able to come out of this Zone and still
make it into other Marvel projects
absolutely absolutely I think that's
always the hope with any of our
characters is that we get to see them
pop up again in in more of their own
shows or movies and then in other shows
and movies with other characters that's
always the right answer the hope and the
promise I just want more of her it's the
truth I know me too all right so now I'm
going to go to the the TV MA thing
because it's the first uh Marvel show to
be rated that way what do you think it
was about this story that that warrant
said that uh Maya Lopez is a badass and
when we meet her she is a villain that's
kind of murdering some people so uh I
don't think we could have done it any
other way if we wanted to make it more
kid-friendly we could have but it might
have taken the edge away from what you
know Maya is and what her story could
have been uh so it would just came with
the the character okay so getting to
play in that space now I am curious is
there any particular scene of the show
where you were kind of doing some some
trial and error in terms of figuring out
how far you could push it with that
rating uh no all the fight scenes
whether they were directed by Sydney
Freeland of course or our director cat
McKenzie who did the skate rink fight uh
good fight yeah they both were like can
we go this far and every step of the way
we were like yes go as far as you want
um and we'll we'll figure it out later
if we went too far or not but we never
did we were even in editorial being like
Oh man how can we push this even further
yeah it was yeah I like it was fun being
able to do this all right now you
brought this up before but it is the
first Marvel show to drop in the binge
watch form what do you think it is about
this story that will make it best
experienced binged rather than watch
week to week sure I think this story is
just one that you want to keep watching
I think it's exciting our episodes are
really awesome and action-packed in a
way that I think you just want to keep
watching and tune in and again on Disney
plus and Hulu and with all of our
television series going forward I think
you'll see different release models for
the story and how they're being told
you'll see what if right now for example
is being released
n episodes Over N nights around the
holidays you know I think each show will
have its own unique thing that really uh
treats the viewers to the best version
of that story keep it fresh I'm open to
that so looking at your run with Marvel
correct me if I'm wrong but I believe
Echo marks your very first executive
producer credit on a show but you've
worked on some of the most iconic films
and shows of the franchise so is there
any past MCU project that you worked on
that you found coming in handy the most
when making your P debut on Echo well I
came right off of doctor strange and the
Multiverse ofis onto eeko
and that movie was you know a big and
crazy monster and this in its own way
was also a big and crazy monster but
different uh they were both fun to make
but going from that to this no not
really that's all it's all the same and
we just got to have fun what was fun
about this one uh compared to Doctor
Strange is it was all happening in
camera and there was hand toand fighting
and it was Al Aqua on set being a badass
and being brutal and there wasn't a lot
of CG backgrounds and stuff and I love
that and I love Doctor Strange in the
multiversal Mania so much so thank you
for asking about it but what was fun
about Ekko was getting to see her
kickass in a skate rink in Oklahoma and
it wasn't multiversal Stakes it was the
stakes of one woman and her family I
love that I have a couple follow-up
questions first one that crossed my mind
because you brought up Al Aqua you
obviously are you know you very much
know how talented she is but when you
hit the echo set is there anything she
did that made you stop and go like I
knew you were good but I didn't realize
you were capable of that yeah two things
one is uh she kicks ass and she is a
Powerhouse and Relentless when it comes
to the action and just wants to do
everything on her own and can do it all
on her own uh and the other thing is
just that she's kind of like Clint
Eastwood in that she does so much with
her face and she's so intimidating and
has such a presence uh and then when
when Sid yells cut um she's AA again and
she's and it's just funny to see her
turn on that badassery I I feel like
that's a pretty good comp right there I
approve of that so going back to what
you were saying before you answered this
kind of with the skate ring question but
I am uh I am curious what do you think
people will see in this show assume it
was done with VFX in post but it was
actually shot in camera interesting I
guess all the fight scenes yeah we we AA
did a lot of it herself we had great uh
stunt choreographers and of course she
had stunt double for some of the bigger
stuff and you know jumping around the
train and everything but all of it was
done mostly in camera are FX team that
we love very much really came in to kind
of do background extensions and stuff
like that but most of the stuff was set
builds and onset it
yeah